Marjorie Taylor green and George Anthony
devolder Santos that's that lying dude
they're co-sponsoring a bill that wants
to ban certain books from schools now I
want to remind you again
Banning books from school at this point
it's trivial in its effect on people
being able to find the books it's so
easy to find books right now okay so
it's less about people won't be able to
read the books because they're banned
it's more about the fact that banning
books has a really really ugly history
and when you start talking about banning
books and banning ideas and and so on
you're really going down a very
fascistic authoritarian Road